في سياق عقدت في القاهره اليوم قمه ثلاثيه
لرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس والعهد
الاردني الملك عبد الله الثاني ورئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي وجاء في البيان
الختامي للقمه التاكيد على ضروره الحفاظ
على الحقوق المشروعه للشعب الفلسطيني كما
اكد البيانو باستمرار الجهود لتحقيق
السلام الشامل والعادل والدائن على اساس
حل الدولتين واشار البيان الى تاكيد القمه
على وجوب وقف كافه الاجراءات الاسرائيليه
الاحاديه اللا شرعيه وضروره الحفاظ على
الوضع التاريخي والقانونيه القائم في
القدس ومقدساتها الاسلاميه والمسيحيه كما
شدد البيان على اهميه استمرار توفير الدعم
المالي لوكاله الغوث الاونروا ومسؤوليه
المالحين الدوليين في جهوده اعماره قطاع
غزه
[موسيقى]